jetzt wird lustig bei klick somit hans
sarpei der unter anderem davon berichtet
dass am anfang überhaupt nichts von
seinem halb mitbekommen hat aber es wird
nicht nur lustig es geht auch um
rassismus im fußball da würde mich und
ihn eure meinung unten in den
kommentaren interessieren darüber hat er
nämlich eine menge zu erzählen also bis
dahin bleibt dann
wie läuft es fußballerisch du bist der
letzte moment ja ganz genau ich bin
momentan verletzt ich habe mich werden
freund spielen lassen wir so ganz blöder
weise einen gegenspieler in mein knie
naja reingesprungen und seitdem habe ich
mich werden ja und mein knie jetzt
momentan bin ich hier in köln in der
reha macht die dort und sehr anstrengend
die krafttraining für das bein damit ich
das immer eine kraft des knies entlastet
aber es läuft ganz gut aber wie kann das
dir passieren wie kann das ansa bei
basieren ich weiß auch nicht ganz genau
aber
mein knie ist nicht mehr das jüngste
deswegen hat es mal gesagt ich brauche
mal ein bisschen ruhe von der mannschaft
glaube ich ein bisschen kraft trainieren
lässt wird okay das nehme ich dann so
hin aber eigentlich genießt du ja im web
dem dem ruf unbesiegbar zu sein ist das
etwas wo du sagst das ist genial oder
ist das störend oder ist das was ist das
für dich diese ich meine das ist ja
bisher noch keinem fußballer in
deutschland passiert dass er zu so einem
web rom gelangt ist
ja ich glaube das kann man auch nicht
irgendwie ich drehe an dass das passiert
einfach oder die leute machen jemanden
dazu und ich glaube
ich finde die stimmung ist genial ist es
ja auch ich dann selber auch darüber
lachen als er das wichtigste ich find's
einfach lustig und mache ja mit was sagt
was sagt deine mannschaft was sagen die
schalker
ach was sagen die ja die die gucken sich
natürlich die sachen auch um an die
kennen die sprüche besser als ich meinte
damit natürlich ab und zu manchmal der
kabine so raus was sie was neues
gehört haben und gesehen haben ist jeder
macht es spaß mit und ja okay was ist
denn dein lieblings hans dabei wird es
den ersten den ich immer gesehen habe
und geil fand das war hand sagt er das l
steht für gefahr
aber ich muss sagen sie ihn verstehen
auch nicht alle
das war es noch lustiger
aber trotzdem zu den kollegen kommt da
nicht langsam mal hier oder befürchtung
machst du dich lächerlich du bist eine
ja du bist eine aber im positiven
natürlich eine witzfigur
gab es da am anfang vielleicht zu
vorbehalten ob das gut ist der
eigentlich überhaupt gar nicht wie ich
schon gesagt ist es sogar
darüber lacht und das ist lustig und
auch die späße oder wird die bande liest
dass man auch mir dann zeigt oder wenn
irgendwas ist und sagt dann zeig mal was
du kannst auch alles macht das und das
und dann macht man darüber war dass
jetzt irgendwann also negativ darauf
irgendwas gesagt hat bis jetzt noch
nicht wie die schon sagt es gibt
natürlich bestimmt immer irgendwelche
leute die das dann negativ aufnehmen
aber ich glaube der größte teil ist
positiv und deswegen ist es schön was
sagt seine familie eigentlich zu dem
hype um dich haben diese direkt
mitbekommen oder ach eigentlich gar
nicht so die die frage mich bis heute
noch was das eigentlich ist wieso und
wie das entstanden ist
ich kann ihnen das ja auch nicht groß
ist sein tag ist ihr müsst einfach
gucken was da passiert sind das ist das
lustig ist
die interessieren sich dafür aber
genau das nicht selber nicht sie können
sich auch nicht für dieses auch
schwieriger diese witze zu verstehen
weil sie mit so nicht so mit der
deutschen sprache so okay aber dass das
lustige ist ja dass du einer der
bekanntesten deutschen fußballer bist
aber nicht weil du die meisten tore
geschossen hast ja das ist ja
ja noch schöner
durch andere art jetzt noch mehr kultur
zu gelangen ok und das ist nicht das was
ich auch am anfang so ein bisschen
verunsichert hat überhaupt gar nicht ich
hab was das problem war auch ich hab das
gar nicht mitbekommen
und
als mir das gesagt wurde habe ich auch
gar nicht darauf reagiert ich hab'
gedacht 'was erzählen ihr denn da was
auf facebook kultig schreiben wie ich
gedacht die leute die die ticken nicht
richtig oder was lesen die denn da und
hab auch keine hab das gar nicht mehr
folgt irgendwann das kann man bei
mehreren mehr ein freund von mir aus
berlin meinte auch da steht so viele
sachen sagt dem verbietet denen das mal
soll er weg machen und ich wusste was
erzählt darin dass wir sachen sagte ja
gibt das mal einen wesen habe ich die
kugel an bord also ja keine ahnung 700
sein sagt was ist das denn woher kommt
das dann hab ich mir das so ein bisschen
angeguckt und dann mit einem kumpel am
telefon ist eigentlich ich hab gelacht
und so hat sich das entstanden und ich
habe das so laufen lassen habe dann
versucht wie jetzt auch meine eigenen
seite alles zu zu basieren ja es ist
gelingt das heißt du hast doch mal
anfang gar nicht mitbekommt weil ich
das heißt deutschland hat japan witze
gemacht und hat dabei
hab es nicht mitbekommen
weil ich muss sagen wie gesagt wenn man
über so fokussiert wie training gehabt
natürlich facebook schon da habe ich
auch da habe ich auch alles angefangen
selber eine seite zu erstellen und war
gerade so
langsam dran die seite für mich zu
machen bilder hochgeladen von
der nationalmannschaft und so hat sich
das dann auf einmal dann ist dieser
party kommen mit den witzen und da habe
ich dann erst rein geschaut dass dann
wurde mir das klar das ist so viele
seiten gab es
und bist du denn inzwischen drauf
ankommt wo eigentlich der ursprung des
ganzen
lag der bei dir oder kampf von dann aus
einer ganz anderen ecke ja dass das das
kann ich jetzt persönlich nicht sagen
wann es wie genau angefangen weil ich ja
selber irgendwie nicht mitbekommen habe
das ist das lustig sein zwischen
den leuten bei web 04
darüber solle sei woche gemacht haben
und da wo baumjohann und ich ja auch
erstmal wieder zurück von den amateuren
zurückgekommen sind der champions league
gespielt haben gegen inter mailand
gewonnen haben da hatten wir auch ein
interview und da habe habe gewonnen und
da hatte ich auch gesagt ja amateure
nicht schlecht dass ich glaub das ist
diese spanne wo das targo entstanden ist
das heißt das liegt dir alles ist dieser
humor das macht ihr spaß ja natürlich du
hast dann auch selbst und ich versuche
der mannschaft paar leute mehr zu
flachsen ok und du füttert das auch mit
mit neuen witzen oder lässt du dir
selber welche einfahren ja natürlich
wären ja auf meiner seite versuche ich
sachen überlege ich mir sachen die auf
die seite zu bringen und wie auch gesagt
es gibt leute die sachen schicken die
eigenen fans wenn sie irgendwas lustiges
haben und dann setze ich das auch auf
meiner seite okay was denkst du denn
damit anzufangen weil ich mal du hast
jetzt mehr als 100.000 facebook
fans bald 8000 voller glaube ich auf
twitter da kann man ja was mit anfang
der woche aus ich weiß nicht was
youtuber werden
ich weiß ich weiß nicht genau wo die
richtung hingeht das ist ja
erstmal ist es ja so ich bin ich bin
immer noch fußballer und die zeit
erlaubt das jetzt nicht so dass ich sage
ich konzentriere mich jetzt 100 prozent
auf facebook oder auch twitter und
gehe jetzt auch hier wie bei euch den
einladungen nach um irgendwas zu machen
ich habe ja schon regelmäßiges training
und wochenende sind spiele und wenn man
auch nicht dabei ist muss man trotzdem
trainieren oder hat freund spiele und da
kann man natürlich nicht alles einfach
so machen man muss das schon irgendwie
abstimmen und mein job ist eben
fußballer zu sein und das geht vor und
daher versucht man alles nebenbei noch
so zu machen
posten und so das kann man ja schon
überall dass es das ist das gute daran
aber wo es dann hingeht das weiß ich
noch nicht genau wann versucht wie jetzt
auf facebook oder twitter die leute noch
immer noch etwas neues zu geben was
lustiges mit denen zusammen zu spielen
die haben ja auch immer lustige sachen
die man die einen zu schicken die die
man kosten kann und dann schaut man in
welche richtung man gehen kann da war
jetzt genau was man machen kann das weiß
ich noch nicht geben weil ich auch nicht
genau weiß wie lange ich noch selber
spiele genau das ist ja ein punkt muss
man sich nicht als fußballspieler das
gesagte knie ist dann netz die
verletzung steigen mit dem
wachsenden alter
muss man sich nicht irgendwann sagen so
jetzt muss ich mal langsam planen für
die zeit und anführungszeichen danach
weil die kann ja ganz schnell kommen
also das kommt irgendwie verletzung aus
dem man nicht mehr raus kommt und das
risiko steigt von dach zu dach wo man
dann sagen muss was mache ich ja das
kann jedem passieren natürlich hast du
recht desto älter man wird desto
ist werde ich auch das risiko aber ich
habe ja schon auch eine lange karriere
hinter mir deswegen bietet wie viele
länder nehmen wie ein bundesliga spieler
setzt
190 irgendwie wahnsinnig und deswegen
muss man schauen
für mich ist es jetzt nicht entscheiden
ich muss ich noch zehn jahre spielen ich
hoffe ich kann noch ein zwei jahre spiel
für mich persönlich aber ich habe in
meiner karriere natürlich alles gespielt
was man spielen kann und da bin ich
glücklich schon froh darüber
aber natürlich hast du recht man muss
sich immer gedanken machen was macht man
danach was was kommt macht man gar
nichts gar nichts wenn man auch nicht
machen will da nicht ganzen tag schlafen
und dann die playstation kammer erfolge
kann man das als fußballspieler nach der
karriere gar nichts mehr machen also
kann man sich das leisten hat man so
viel verdient in der aktiven karriere
dass man sagen kann so jetzt gehe ich in
rente ja was heißt gar nichts machen ich
glaub ich glaube nicht ist glaube ich
erstens ist es langweilig 2 ich glaube
vom geld her
will man ja irgendwann auch mal so ein
standard halten und deswegen muss man
glaube ich schon was machen um geld zu
verdienen aber man ist glaube ich als
fußballer nach einer karriere nicht
gezwungen alles zu machen man kann sich
schon aussuchen ok mache ich dass dies
die sachen in sachen rauspicken und auch
selber entscheiden dann was sie machen
weil sie natürlich einen background
haben wo vielleicht nicht bei jedem aber
geld schon nicht mehr so die rolle
spielt dass man jedes angebot annehmen
muss dass
so sehe ich das ja zu enttarnen bei mir
und jetzt hat glaube ich habe ich die
zeit wo ich mich irgendwie eine richtung
orientieren kann
dass sie jetzt so schön ist dass ich
facebook und twitter habe dass ich
gleich auf diesen zug da irgendwo rennt
aufspringen kann und was bei für mich
persönlich machen kann ist es auch sehr
schön wobei da ist ja schon was daraus
entstanden der springer konzern hatte
ich zum beispiel als werbefigur gebucht
mit dem slogan die bild -zeitung kann
man knicken hat es bei mir ganz genau
weil ich glaub weil es in aktion sehr
lustig leute waren natürlich wie
gespalten einige fans gut und ist schön
einige nicht so schön dass wegen der
bild zeitung dass man für die bild
werbung gemacht aber ich glaube es kam
auch was gutes dabei haben 10.000 euro
gespendet für eine gute organisation und
das ist auch ganz schön absolut hast du
denn irgendeine richtung die du machen
willst youtuber vielleicht nicht aber
was anderes wo du sagst das wird mir
liegen das kann man daraus machen jetzt
überhaupt noch gar nicht überhaupt noch
kann ich habe mir so intensiv noch gar
keine gedanken gemacht
in welche richtung es gehen soll das ist
aber auch eine gute frage dass die ich
auf facebook und twitter auch stellen
kann in den leuten irgendwann fragen ja
die können ja ihre vorschläge da geben
bisher ist ich glaube auch ganz gute
frage da wird glaube ich genug kommen
und mal schauen wo es hin geht es
vielleicht es kann ja auch sein dass ich
das man irgendwas dann nach der karriere
auf schalke aber was macht weil die zwei
jahre wie ich jetzt da bin habe ich
schon dem fallen lieben gelernt und auch
die art und weise wie die fans hinter
dem verein stehen und wie verrückt sie
sind ist schon einzigartig
ein besonderer verein das ist ja auch
der einzige feind da ist man nicht im
stadion sah erstmal auf schalte
ich habe schon in anderen vereinen
gespielt und da kommen jetzt nicht so
viele fans und dann die videos
unterstützen dann willst den fans
natürlich immer alles wieder geben 100
120 prozent geben um erfolg zu haben
auch dass sie natürlich dafür jubeln
können und da passiert es dann dass man
sie verletzt ja das gab es in dem
geschäft dazu dafür sind wir natürlich
20 25 leute im kader und der trainer hat
da nehmen wir die möglichkeit anderen
heute bei einzusetzen
man macht sich mal warten vertrag
qualitäts vertrag dass wenn man sie
verletzt dass man bestimmte summe
ausgezahlt bekommen aber nachdem man
diesen vertragen was hat da denkt man
gar nicht mehr dran wenn man zum
training geht zum spiel geht denkt man
nicht so wenn vier verletzte dann kann
das zuvor bei sein oder nicht man
trainiert und versucht gas zu geben 100
prozent versucht seinen stammplatz sich
zu sichern und ja manchmal gibt es
situationen wo man nachher vielleicht
sieht und sagt oh mein gott deswegen da
hätte man nicht hingehen
müssen sollen aber weil man nicht daran
denkt und man will den ball haben und
will das spiel gewinnen und dann gibt
man alles für sich und auch die
mitspieler und für den verein und wenn
nachher was schlimmes passiert dann
sollte es so sein da wollte der liebe
gottes nicht aber
ich glaube wenn man auch darüber
nachdenken dass man sich verletzen kann
da verletzte sich erst recht wenn du
sagst du gibt es 120 prozent geben alle
fußball 320 prozent ja natürlich glauben
können spieler will verliert was ist
dein eindruck dass man manchmal wirklich
ein alles perfekt läuft alles
ineinandergreifen zahnrädchen und
manchmal einfach alles quer steht
ich glaube zuerst ist die einstellung
hat besonders in der bundesliga ist sehr
schwer ist es nicht so wie in italien
oder spanien wo
34 mannschaften da oben mitspielen und
der rest wir verlieren gegen die
mannschaften oben sowieso hier in der
bundesliga kann jeder jeden schlagen
weil
alle mannschaften
so laufen können so kämpfen da macht es
da ist es so minimal da muss man seine
qualitäten so genau ausschöpfen ob bei
münchen auch da sonst verliert man auch
gegen der mannschaft die da unten steht
wie augsburg oder so und man kann nicht
alles planen natürlich so dass die
eigentlich gewinnen müssten aber wäre ja
auch für uns zuschauer oder alles
schlecht wenn wir schon vorher wussten
dass bayern die am meisten verdient
deutscher meister wird setzt sich ja
gegen rassismus ein gibt es ist das
schon mal ausgenutzt worden mit
rassistischen tendenzen oder hat er ist
das gar nicht passiert
ist das überhaupt ist das eigentlich im
fußball so ist das ein thema oder ist
diese haben wir die aktivitäten die es
im fußball gibt gegen rassismus haben
die schon so früchte getragen dass man
sagen kann hey das ist in dem bereich wo
man sagen kann ist alles okay ich bin ja
jetzt schon länger dabei und muss sagen
da habe ich habe zeit liga gespielt und
sohn an wenn du dann osten gespielt das
war es schon hart
das als farbiger das spiel war echt echt
hart da wurde es recht
bepöbelt und angemacht und jetzt ist es
dieses wird immer besser ja ist das was
was ein
bedrückt das ganze leben oder ist es
etwas was man
was so zum leben dann gehört wenn man
als farbiger in deutschland aufwächst
dass man es quasi ganz mehr wahrnimmt
man weiß es ja von kindheit aus und
nimmt es dann irgendwann
ja nicht als normaler dabei wann hat es
als kind irgendwie mitgenommen und weiß
was wie die leute drauf sind und
und macht sich aber nicht mehr so viele
gedanken
desto jünger man ist dann
beschäftigt das einem glaube ich mehr na
ja und wenn du das natürlich erlebt hast
dann das bleibt dein ganzes leben weil
er weiß wie die leute denken und wenn du
als kind irgendwo einkaufen gehst und
und ein anderes kind seien nicht nicht
mal als kind ja auch wenn du erwachsen
bist und an andere kinder haben noch nie
einen farbigen gewinns im raum aber was
ist das es wird und die mutter agiert
das ist legal dann denkst du dir auch so
das ist ja bloß mit der frau hatte keine
ahnung aber das wird sich jetzt groß
sagen alles was so sagt wird so gut
streiten weil sie ja keine ahnung hat
und ihrem kind irgendwas falsch ist da
wieder bringt und lernst damit dann
umzugehen und
beschäftigt sich selbst damit und
versuchst natürlich in jeder art egal ob
das ist sport in der schule ist muss
versuchen besser zu sein als die anderen
und ich irgendwie besser zu stellen und
zu sagen ja ich bin hier und bin
trotzdem
gut ist das eine motivation für dich
gewesen zum fußball sowie natürlich klar
und
ich glaube ich glaube dass ich auch ist
jetzt noch so wenn du
frage ja bis muss ich schon dass ich
nicht hat beim fußball ist ja ist ja
immer konkurrenz da und du darfst dich
dann nicht auf einer augenhöhe von
seinem konkurrenten stellen man muss
immer einen tick besser zusammen gehen
damit was euro das der ist schon gut
weil warum sondern dich nehmen werden
gleichfalls
als einer der hier im land ist
ja wobei du bist ja hier im land ja
natürlich
ich fühle mich auch wenn wir groß
geworden und fühle mich auch gut hier
und ich würde aber sagen deutschland ist
super ich würde nicht in einem anderen
land leben wollen es ist ja ich finde
deutschland
aber wie bist du dann zum fußball
gekommen war das so dass du dich dass du
dann konkreten ausweg gesucht hast und
sagt ich muss irgendwas tun oder war das
nicht so eine bewusst sehr
entscheidender stelle das war auch gar
nicht nur bewusster entscheidung es ist
einfach so dass man mit fußball
schnellsten andere leute kennenlernt als
kind besonders war es ja sogar meine
zeit noch dass wir draußen auf dem
bolzplatz gespielt haben oder leer
ausgegangen bis zehn kinder da und
spielt fußball dann lernst alle kennen
und ihr seid freunde
helfen das geht ganz schnell wäre ihr
kennt euch nicht kommst raus hätten weil
jeder will spielen ihr spielt gegen dann
der miteinander und hast dreck neue
freundin kennengelernt innerhalb von
zehn minuten
so
nimmt der eine den anderen mit und zeigt
wo der spät im verein las war zusammen
hingehen und dann
gehts feldmann ein verein zu spielen mit
sechs jahren und man liebt dann der in
den sport dann gebt so geht es weiter
das heißt der fußball ist wirklich nicht
nur manchmal so denken das gefühl das
ist so ein pr da stellen sich die
fußballspieler vor auffahrt vom spielen
mit seinem banner und manchmal denkt man
oh gott die haben wir überhaupt keinen
bock dazu aber wie du das beschreibt ist
der ball ja wirklich ein verbindendes
element
total ich ich ich muss auch sagen zum
beispiel die weltmeisterschaft
wenn sie jetzt für ghana ich hab mir für
ghana gespielt und in der zeit war so
politik rat ein bisschen unruhe und als
die wärme angefangen hat dann hast du
gesehen wie das ganze land
einst wurde und sich hinter uns gestellt
hat und wollte dass wir gewinnen und da
siehst du was wir die mannschaft
eigentlich fußball mit einem land machen
kann so das sind eigentlich zwei weiten
die wollen eine wolle die partei die
andere die partei und wir wacher bringen
die alle zusammen und die jubeln so das
gleiche land und wollen dass wir
weiterkommen und dass ich dann einen
teil dabei bin von der
nationalmannschaft und das land so
zusammenbringen ist es ist
unbeschreiblich so ist einfach wir haben
überragend man ist stolz dass das dann
in der in diesem moment auch keine
gewalt ist kein keine unruhe und das
alle in eine gleiche richtung
wie
ist das eigentlich ghana wie wirst du da
begrüßt empfangen
verehrt ja ist ein bisschen anders
natürlich das was ich danach zum
beispiel bin
kenne mich die leute und dann ist es
schon ist nicht so einfach so raus zu
gehen und feiern zu gehen oder essen zu
gehen dann stehen natürlich vor dem
türen schon leute und warten bis ich
wieder rauskommen
autogramme zu haben und mit mir sprechen
zu können so also ein absoluter
superstar ja was heißt superstars ja das
ist schon einiges los und ist ihm das
auch so bewusst dass das so einigen
quasi die wm
ich glaube schon dass ihnen das bewusst
wahr sie sind meine sie haben ja
gewonnen und dann wir waren in südafrika
aber haben nur gehört was in ghana los
ist und die leute sind auf den straßen
und haben miteinander gefeiert und sind
da abgegangen waren stolz auf ghana
ja natürlich
wir hätten natürlich darauf dass hier
noch weiter kommen sie heute
noch stolz machen aber es sollte nicht
sein ich glaube
die leute sind so schon genug
ausgeflippt und wenn wir noch
weiterkommen sind werden noch viel
härter fakt
ist dass ein erfülltes leben
ja was heißt erfülltes leben es ist es
ist nicht so einfach wie die leute
denken leute sehen und samstags sonntags
spielen und denken dass das war es wie
einst spielen also so einfach ist es
nicht sie sehen nicht die ganze woche
wie der einzelne
sich da quält und abrackert damit er
samstag seine leistung bringen kann oder
wenn einige verletzt sind wie die partie
kämpfen um wiederzukommen und ist ja
viel kopfsache auch und man muss
versuchen
sich irgendwie frei zu machen damit man
samstags topfit ist und die leistung
auch abrufen kann jeder weiß dass dieser
spieler die qualität hat
jemanden der alle habt ihr alleine
auseinanderzunehmen und kann die beim
spielen nicht abgerufen jeder denkt
sicher weiß los mit dem es kann doch
nicht sein da verdienen so viel geld wie
das schiff dann auf das geld und weiß
aber gar nicht was mit der person los
ist weil ich hatte auch kleiner
wehwehchen die 1 grad für das spiel
steuern und darüber machen die leute
natürlich keinen gedanken und sie
deswegen nicht so einfach und so schön
wie sich das ist immer wie es
dargestellt wird und so ist es ist es
natürlich ist es nicht natürlich ist es
schön fußballprofi zu sein
meinst du du kannst noch mal
stammspieler werden bei schalke oder
kann so was dich auch komplett raus
werfen ja das ist das kann mich
natürlich auch komplett raus werfen aber
stammspieler nochmals aktiv werden das
ist jetzt schwer ich habe die saison
endet in fünf wochen und das ist ja das
wird nicht so schnell hin klappen
deswegen aber weil vertrag endet auch
ende der saison und deswegen wollen muss
immer schauen muss man suchen wo sich
jetzt fit zu werden und wenn man gesund
ist dann kann man den nächsten schritt
dann wieder angehen was wie es dann
weitergeht bist du wirklich so entspannt
wie du jetzt redest oder fiebers zu
diesem vertragsende entgegen nach dem
motto oh gott was wird da jetzt
passieren danach ja eigentlich nicht so
entspannt wirklich wirklich natürlich
bin ich mit 35 werde im juni 36 wenn ich
jetzt nicht entspannt wer
das war
wenn ich jetzt wenn einer jetzt jünger
ist und 25 welches dem 20
der vertrag wurde aus laufen und ich
hatte noch keinen neuen vertrag beim und
bin verletzt da würde ich mir natürlich
gedanken machen wie sie sagen ich muss
fit werden und dann wenn man auch fit
wird dann weiß man trotzdem nicht wo es
hingeht
die mannschaften natürlich angst haben
keiner weiß wie die wie gesund wirklich
bist und wie ob man ein jetzt doch
verpflichten soll oder nicht aber ich
bin jetzt 35 habe auch schon
verletzungen gehabt und weiß kann in
meinen körper auch so rheinhausen weiß
wie es ist wie es ist und ich weiß dass
ich wenn ich
fit bin
ja ok das heißt du willst noch egal auch
wenn das ausläuft du machst nur weil ja
natürlich ja
gut dann dabei sehr viel erfolg dass
hinter vielen dank trenk auch mehr talk
zum beispiel den letzten millionen ab
die in dem er lernen könnt warum
cannabis konsum also ihr könnt es quasi
lernen ist untertrieben ihr nehmt es in
euch auf ihr seht es vor euren augen
warum cannabiskonsum hungrig macht und
auch sehr spannend der talk mit rat in
dem er erklärt warum bei einer
autogrammstunde von ihm die polizei ein
wenig überfordert war oder total
überfordert irgendwie sowas also da oder
dort entscheidet euch ganz
ansonsten bis dann bleib dran